there are stories and then there are
stories basketball hall of famer spencer
haywood
has lived enough for five lives and he
tells stories in a new book called
the spencer haywood rule without that
rule there isn't a kid going right from
high school to the nba like kobe or
lebron
you've never heard of the term one and
done if it isn't for spencer
that's the spencer haywood rule he
fought for his right to make a living
his plea went all the way to the supreme
court and now
all that much more written on the pages
of this new book
and and my brothers and sisters and my
mother
we worked in the field from sun up to
sun down
trying to make a just to eek out of a
living
you know to try to get it going so it's
just
just thinking about it it's hard but it
was fair
one day i was i was thinking about it
and i was trying to figure out how did i
develop with both hands
and how did i develop my legs because i
was picking cotton from two rows
you know with both hands so i learned to
be delicate with my fingers
and i dragged the sack weighed 100
pounds at 10 and 12 years old
so i put the sack on your back and you
walk through the trailer to dump the
trailer
so i was it was god developing me into a
basketball
and i thought i was going to be the best
cotton picker
that's counting and that state had ever
overseen
so i was practicing i've seen people
dead hangings
and so much so much abuse
and i've seen so many people on my side
of the street
uh blacks were abusing themselves and
abusing each other because of
what the examples that they had seen in
front of them so
yeah then the good the good is your
mother you had a real strong
relationship with your mother didn't say
that a strong relationship with mama
mama eunice
and she always would say baby you know
the lord may not come when you want him
but he's always right on time and that's
from mahalia jackson
so when i made it all the way to the
hall of fame
my closing speech and the closing words
of my speech was that
because i reflect right back to where i
was
the way i was growing up in mississippi
and that's what brought out all of the
joy
of that moment when i got ready to go to
the olympics
we didn't have a birth certificate
i didn't have a birth certificate
because i was born by the midwife
and she didn't register me with the
state of jackson
at the vital statistics in jackson
mississippi so i had no birth
certificate
so we had to go they said mrs haywood
can you send up the birth certificate
to um to colorado springs i mean to
where we were
getting ready to head off to russia she
says yes baby but i can't send my bible
it was written in the bible under john
21.
so when there they sent someone from the
jackson
newspaper down to my mom's house in
silver city took a picture of it
then they went and got uh developed a
birth certificate and that's how i got
the birth certificate so i got a
passport so i could go
to the olympics when i was fighting all
the way to the supreme court
it was like you're in politics you can't
change the rules you can't do these
things you know
and then at the same time i was there we
had kurt flood who was fighting for
baseball
and then you also had muhammad ali who
was fighting
for the rights of boxers and
citizens throughout the world so there's
always been a social
they say social movement
most players don't know who i am and
what i've done
for them and their family because
it's been polluted with the idea that
first they call it the hardship rule
second they call it
uh what is it early entry
third they call it one and done and it's
always been haywood v nba
this is the u.s supreme court ruling
which we are celebrating today
the 50th anniversary of it and so
now we have the book the spencer hayward
rule
and now we have the commissioner and the
plea the players association
are getting ready to rename the ruling
as it should have been
for years now the spencer hay will grow
and that's uh
that's a blessing the poor boy from
silver city mississippi
whether it's
what a great guy we appreciate spencer
haywood hanging out with those a little
bit still ahead of